you do things without my consent or
without my know-how but now it might
might I just find out you're doing these
nicotine patches no I do them all day
hmm okay do you want one no I have a
weird thing about all of this and you
know what it is I just figured it out
you know why I don't go on TRT
sure I don't do anything like that or
just your [ __ ] it's not that I'm a
little bit arrogant so what I do is I go
like this I go my immune system my
natural state is better than anything
science could offer [ __ ] I'm wrong
psoriasis and all my friendships is the
worst I've ever seen
well that was stress but all my friends
I called it all my friends are on
something except for you and but I mean
older friends do you mean on some well
they're all doing okay you know and
they're all laugh at me and they go you
should do because you have no idea so I
feel like I'm gonna open a card and be
like oh you know but but then again I
don't need any more energy my dick and
cut a diamond right now that's what I
want to [ __ ] with I'm a mama I got I got
very good energy do you have the best
energy I do you can go I don't know if I
want to [ __ ] with things that take time
and stuff or whatever ha people politics
now it's not if I get seven a half hours
sleep daddy doesn't mean a nap I go hard
the other thing I do is I work out but
not too crazy where I don't have
injuries everybody I know who works out
too much there's something they always
get it right there's you as an athlete
know this you know what I'll do is I'll
do I'll do it and then I'll just stop
when I feel like I want to do that I
want Jesus look at my stomach without
any TRT at 50 no no you get a great body
dude I don't but you know hey I want you
to apologize for saying I was a
professional athlete in front of work
man well I'm proud of you being Harley
keep calling me professor look at my
body I'm alright I didn't I was there
that night you're singing your ass I did
alright you did great you gave me a bit
of a compliment I went was I good you
went yeah you're the best really the
best by far the best that it was I
appreciate because you went I didn't
have I was good or I didn't I knew it
was fun I filmed it it was phenomenal
and they asked me to do it now the was
it the def jam will find a song for you
I got the phone what
Dave Matthews dude oh now look at me
crash into me
satellite Jackson smooth sup Jackson
Jack smooth just Jackson Jackson went up
by what I'm gonna say your full-name
Jack words motor surf and turf surfer
surf or turf or listen to me right now
let's after your your your now listen
Dave Matthews is a vocalist now I I
don't need you trying to do Dave
Matthews you want me to do Queen or Sun
you can't do that you read your journey
what do you think it where you going
with this you can't do those guys you
don't think probably need to make a very
easy song satellite in my eyes you don't
think I couldn't talk about matter ties
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]